To start solving this inequality, let's clear our groupings by distributing. I
want to distribute this negative 2 and this positive 2. I'm showing my
distribution in this step here, being really careful with my negative 3. It's
negative 3 times negative 1. I'm going to combine like terms on each side of the
inequality. I have 5 plus 3, which gives me 8, and 6 plus 1, which gives me 7. I
bring down the negative 3m, and the 2m. I add 3m to both sides to keep my
variable positive. A positive 5m and no more M's on the left. Next, I subtract 7
from both sides to isolate the 5m. Finally, I divide by 5 on both sides to get 1
5th is less than or equal to M. That's the same thing as M being greater than or
equal to 1 5th M is greater than or equal to 1 5th, so that must be answer
choice A.